for decades local government and
business leaders have tried to diversify
our economy just so we're not so
dependent on resorts a new report aims
to find ways to achieve that the vegas
chamber reached out to the brookings
mountain west institute over at unlv and
try to highlight ways to form an
economic development plan for our
community vegas chamber president and
ceo mary beth seawall says it is
important to expand the diversity
outside of the gaming industry we do
need to diversify and we've known that
for a long time so one of the
recommendations is to better align
education and workforce development with
the needs of businesses
you know especially industries that need
those higher skilled workers so it's
it's really a significant reason why we
have a hard time attracting those tech
based companies
another idea to pass a policy that would
give entrepreneurs more funding so they
can help diversify and go into other
aspects of the economy the chamber is
going to discuss these findings at a
luncheon on thursday over at the orleans